[Music]
that's not a good start potato great
start okay so have you give your dry
Tito before are they just crisps no
they're not just crisps
yeah okay so well if you want a mermaid
on it I will not want mama I think
you'll like this okay okay it's also
half nine I'm eating crisp sandwiches so
that's a good start to anything okay
what are you doing what are you checking
no it's a crisp you've never had a crisp
sandwich that's all thanks though okay
so you can have okay all right bro all
right bro I forgot I feel like I'm gonna
put it all down me I'm definitely gonna
pour it eat it over the place
yeah yeah all right ready
okay
it's nice right